So after having recently watched Black
Mirror,
it struck me at the shows.
Most genuinely unsettling episodes don't
just blatantly show a highly negative
dystopian future.
Instead they take us for a ride and
reflect to us a vision of the future.
Highly compatible with our own current
desires,
the desires you capture,
share and hold onto the past.
Because the way
in the entire history of you,
this desire to hold onto our memories
has manifested itself in the grain.
A device connected to our signups is
that records everything your eyes see.
You can replay your recordings or your
reduce esther called at any given time,
showed them to your friends and family
or hand them over to to forties when
everyday.
So require you to,
if you just really wanted me,
I lost 24 hours.
The story makes it abundantly clear that
the widespread integration of the grain
in society has enormous implications for
the privacy of its characters.
That's the room that many respects
that's lost nearly all of its meaning in
a since been replaced rather by his
sentiment that can roughly be described
us.
Nothing to hide,
nothing to fear.
We can see the implementation of this
mindset right here and the airport
scene.
The big thing,
just how or rally and the government has
become in favor of its own security,
but we also see it manifested in the
workplace as Liam's law firm demands
access to their employees,
reduce in order to ensure their
productivity,
loyalty,
and security for the image of the
company.
And although the implementation of the
grain has not been made mandatory,
it's been highly normalized to the
degree that grainless before stigmatized
as having something to hide and being
degenerate,
which is in turn supported by the fact
that police won't respond to calls for
help from grainless citizens and why
it's is promoted as being cheaper than a
cup of coffee.
It's a power structure that at first
glance seems to benefit the forces in
positions of power.
Calling back to Jeremy Bentham,
Scott set with the Panopticon,
which is a version of a rounded prison
with a tower in the center in which a
guard could watch every individual
prisoner at any time,
but the prisoners and dare turn could
not see to guard and therefore would
never know whether they were being
watched or not.
So if you're radically creating self
disciplinary prisoners now to use this
concept as a metaphor in relation to our
own society is as clear as day in
frankly somewhat on the nose.
The big thing,
the dangers of unlimited surveillance
and personal data mining and the lack of
balance between the watcher and watched
the entire history of you,
however,
shows in near future in which everyone
now effectively has inherited both those
roles acting bove as a living,
breathing,
CCTV camera,
your bitch.
I'd like you to erase that as well as
the object passing through its frame.
Not gonna hit anything to freak us out.
How that they're not,
there's no major deletions this quarter.
No,
no,
no.
Everything's a well within prophetess.
However,
it would be a mistake to conclude that
the green is merely a product of some
level in police state as it seems to be
more of a natural outcome of years upon
years of increasingly sharing our
personal lives from taking selfies to
the recording of concerts to
lifestreaming your life for the entire
world.
To see there never was a need to make
grain mandatory because who wouldn't
want to share and relive the good old
times during a nice reunion dinner.
And this is read the entire history of
you shines the most by refraining from
focusing on the more obvious and already
broadly covered bigger picture and
instead minimizing its aim onto what
interests us most,
the personal and the coziness of a warm
lead lid living room it relatable scene
showing nuance and it's social
commentary making us comfortable before
ultimately showing its true ugly face
during this painfully horrific scene at
both the state of Lehman fees,
marriage becomes obvious as well as the
way in which degree in synthetically he
keeps both of them stuck in the past,
completely disconnected from their
present selves.
Liam chosen to be the main focus of the
story functions as a prime example of
this obsession.
We seed in his role as a litigation
lawyer dealing solely with redo cases,
but it's also noticeable in a slight but
consistent social awkwardness seemingly
never being really present to the moment
using reduced to remember the name of
one of his wife's best friends because
who needs an actual memory when you have
to grain.
But where it's most evident is in is
mistrust of his wife's faithfulness.
Starting from the moment he sees her
chatting with Jonas,
he rapidly descends into a full blown
paranoia,
effectively prosecuting his wife using
evidence from years ago.
So when week or a month as lean tries to
drink away and perhaps indulge into
pain,
has investigation is causing him.
We noticed that this might very well be
his share behavior seen in friends,
family,
and even the work environment.
And it's really no wonder that the
indulgence of these mind numbing
substances plays such a prevalent role
in the society as various mirror shots
indicate how the grain has caused part
of Liam's personality to split,
to stay behind,
and they has been time,
but it has been timed that can never be
automatically let go off and it has the
potential to come crashing down on you
if you're not paying attention.
Liam,
in the end forces his wife to expose him
to the truth.
And the most visceral way imaginable is
marriage now in ruins.
He ponders about better times rewinding
them and perhaps wishing he had really
lift those moments when they were still
real.
And even though he turned out to be
right in this obsessive paranoia,
seeing how Lehman fear almost always
shown apart from each other,
one can only wonder what it was this
brokenness to over analyze,
to live in the past rather than in the
present.
That caused a rift in our marriage long
before the event's shown on screen.
So obsessed.
I'm not,
in the end,
Leah knows that having a grain will
never allow him to move on,
that it would always keep him a prisoner
of his own mind and it's at that point
and he realizes that the only way he
will ever escape this vicious cycle is
to literally cut off that that would
have the past.
And
finally coming back into the now.
That concludes this video essay.
Thank you all so much for watching.
And if you want to support the channel,
you can hop over to our patrion page or
consider leaving a onetime donation in
our paypal account in a day or two.
I will drop my additional video
commentary for this video essay on our
patrion page.
I think the entire history view is one
off,
if not the best black mirror episode to
date.
And I hope I showed you why exactly it
is in this video.
Um,
you know,
I think that's it for today.
Would you consider following us on
facebook and maybe twitter as we do
actually post things on there?
Thanks for watching guys.